never underestimate the power of a good
medic the ability to revive and heal
your teammates can dramatically turn the
tide of a battle so if you're going to
be playing medic you want to make sure
you know what you're doing here are some
tips for those of you playing medic in
battlefield one let's start with the
basics you're going to want to always be
around teammates keeping everyone healed
no one benefits from a medic that
decides to lonewolf it here yourself
with the assault class your rifle will
complement their submachine gun nicely
and you can keep them alive while they
deal with those tanks you're completely
useless against because healing is your
number one priority you also want to
stay in the back of your squad drop a
med pack if you know if I is going to
break out so you can get healing as
quickly as possible you can throw your
bandages at a pretty decent range
meaning you can safely stay in cover
when healing your allies and if a guy
goes down revive him just remember to
make sure that the people who kill them
are dead first we are losing objective
doc this is a battlefield game after all
and the medic gets to shoot with the
rifle you got the rigotti as your
default which is a pretty good
middle-of-the-road gun at the m-19 07
which is perfect for those who want a
little more up close approach the au
variants auto fire turns it into a
shotgun like weapon capable a quick-fire
carrying this with the gas grenade is a
great way to storm a control point and
finally there's the Mondragon for those
of you wanting more range its long-range
scope gives you a more sniper like role
and is my personal preference but even
with these options remember you are not
the person who should be taking point on
attack or camping out with a rifle
you're a medic first and foremost and as
long as you support your teammates and
keep them alive you're doing a good job
you have any cool moments as a medic
please share them in the comments and
subscribe the game spot for even more
battlefield 1 videos
you